we start this hour with news from the  attorney general nevada is fighting back  in the opioid crisis and now we've got  some financial help to kind of push us  along today attorney general aaron ford  announced our state will be receiving  settlement money from pharmaceutical  companies for their role in the opioid  crisis a.j ford says thousands of  nevadans have died and this money will  help leaders move forward and make  changes  this money comes at a perfect time  as april is the national month of hope  we've joined together and brought money  and to give hope to people of nevada  and to those who've suffered from the  devastation and impact of this horrible  epidemic  clark county alone will receive 22  million dollars from a more than 285  million dollar settlement a.g ford also  highlighted nevada continues to be one  of the hardest hit states with the death  rate still spiking so he's hoping this  money will help change that statistic